and the idea that the state of longing  is actually healthy in that way rumi the  the 12th century sufi poet well here's  this one poem where he's talking about  um  about a man who's praying to god and he  doesn't get an answer back and so he  becomes kind of  bitter and disappointed and he stops  praying and then he falls into a sleep  and he's not sleeping well  and  who's the guide of souls comes along to  him and says why did you stop praying  and the man says because i never got an  answer  and the guide of souls says to him  the longing that you express that is the  return message  and the grief that you cry out from is  exactly what draws you towards union  this is the message that we get again  and again from these traditions like the  grief is what draws you towards the  ultimate love that you seek